hi I'm Erik Bosse I'm Philip Molina and
this is a great town of Game of Thrones
season 7 premiere title Dragonstone so
welcome everybody if you are new to
these videos we like to go super
incredibly in-depth in our analysis
pointing out all the moments that you
might have missed and subtle connection
to the book even the history of Westeros
plus a ton of influences from our real
world culture but also all these awesome
little layers of meaning and the visuals
and the editing and music and dialogue
set design costumes fart sound effects
we are going to break it down super
in-depth there's a lot of rich thematic
subtext by the way this is the season
premiere of Game of Thrones so it is so
packed this is gonna be a like mega
fully loaded video I would lay back if I
were you just laugh get comfortable yeah
and then after that maybe you know go
for so sweetly with a shot with mob
Garen and we talked about all kinds of
awesome stuff there too and predictions
and stuff it's great great let's get
started okay we're going back before I
get the amazing cold opens that happen
which is not a common thing I have to
talk about the previously on logs
they've been putting so much meaning to
these lately
so these are the purposes just to remind
you of specific scenes from past
episodes instead of the scenes of this
episode and this one yeah does that
really well but it's everything else
that's going on in the previously on
like for instance if you hear it there's
a piano in there and now pianos are fair
game for the first time in Game of
Thrones history they use pianos and the
instrumentation in the season six finale
[Music]
and now we get it right here at the
beginning and in addition to those piano
notes notice how the editing of this
whole sequence is super jarring like
it's calm and quiet and then suddenly
there's just a burst of sound as the
Wildfire flows in people scream I think
all that is just to make us feel super
on edge at the beginning of this episode
and at the beginning of the season
like there's all kinds of surprising
violence that could sneak up on us at
any moment but now going straight into
the actual amazing mind-blowing
cold-open scene that felt like it was
its own freakin movie note the cloth
over the hand if you think about what's
happened here it means Arya has made
Bray gloves
she's wearing his skin
like their sleeves that our Rockstar
wears I love it yeah and sign note about
cold opens in general it's pretty rare
on Game of Thrones to see a scene that
plays before the credits like they've
only done it about six times they did in
the pilot in the season premiere of
season three four and five and then they
did it one time last season hi that Rory
McCann was going to appear at an episode
again now and I think the reason they do
this is that it's meant as a teaser for
the whole season to kind of set the tone
of what kind of season this is going to
be and specifically in this case we
notice how arias storyline here feels
like it's outside of the events of the
show right like this is crazy she's
using false identities and amazingly
perfect vocal impressions of Walter gray
it kind of feels like something that
might be in a Mission Impossible movie
or that this is a scene out of a
Tarantino killbill movie re s Kill Bill
do it send it to us hashtag NOx artists
will [ __ ] on a show if only she had a
list of people she was going to kill and
it would be perfect oh wait she does
who's on that list are we gonna do now
you might as well okay who's left
remaining Cersei Lannister the mountain
beric Dondarrion throws me around the
Hound will she thinks the Hound is dead
so I then exit out the red woman is on
that list though and who can forget Sir
Ilyn Payne I'd be nothing you don't have
no tongue so we love about him but
moving back into the cold open per
second know what already is session
together
she uses the Frey house words stand
together
she also then later boasts the idea of
the wolf left alone he's blond wolf
alive I'm gonna shake my never fade so
if you think about it Arya loved saying
that they all stand together like sheep
and she gets to be that lone wolf to
just count them all up but the problem
with that is as we saw in the teaser
Sansa was repeating that phrase about
the language dies at the peck slice of
course quoting her father Ned Stark that
explaining how that starts going to stay
together when the winter arrives Arya
taking pride in being the lone wolf is
kind of a bad sign for her and then
moving on to which it was a little later
who didn't slaughter every one of the
stocks that was your mistake
you should have ripped them all out
and Stan ripped them out ruins them it's
kind of a reference to something pycelle
has said in the book but actually I
think it's much more interesting that
she is so contrasted right now with Ned
Stark who had the exact same dilemma in
front of him but whether or not the
Targaryen should be ripped out wooden
stem and he's the one that tells Robert
Baratheon no no no don't kill every
single last one of them that's just a
little girl and now in this case two
little girls that were not wrist out
wooden stem have come for vengeance okay
so now we get to the real opening images
of the episode and it's this long static
shot of an icy terrain from brand point
of view indecision and notice how the
wind is blowing away from the camera
meanwhile the white Walker way into the
distance is blowing towards the camera
so this is a really disorienting surreal
book something in a nightmare and yeah
this is a long static shot and lasts for
nearly two minutes unbroken and it's
symmetrical which is actually a director
trademark of the director this episode
Johnny québécois and yeah this is meant
to make us feel like we feel like in a
normal nightmare as we're static not
able to move as this do moves its way
toward us to have like Michael Myers in
Halloween or in the movie it follows but
actually my favorite things that's going
on in this vision is if you look closely
look at what all these lights are
wearing it's the latest and free-falls
fashion this is what everyone was
wearing at hardhome which means those
that were risen there are now officially
part of the undead army but even more
shocking is the giant whites that also
went down there and other places above
the wall and everybody's asking a lot of
us is one of them one one which was that
one actually the actor who played one
one Ian white is credited in this
episode so maybe things maybe that could
be one one resurrected and one one is
missing an eye right Randy shot of that
was an error in the battle the bastard
but that I was one one right eye whereas
this giant white is missing his left eye
so being this is probably a different
giant Theory busted maybe eating I hope
so because I don't want one one to be
bad but I also love one one so I want to
see him come back even if he's done that
but maybe Siri unbond
because look at what's under the snow
here that looks like it could be grass
making me think that maybe this location
isn't north of the wall but it's
actually south of the wall and what
Brandes seen here is the future we know
that in his visions in the past he's
been able to see into the future and
maybe what we're seeing here are
actually all the dead from the battle
the bastards and all the conflicts top
the wall resurrecting and moving the way
further is out on the other side of the
frickin wall our side of the wall since
we're in this kind of theory time mini
theory time right now I'm going to throw
in a little theory - there's a giant
back there who looks like he's carrying
a longbow so in the books back during
Aegon's conquest there was a thought
that maybe there was a way to resist
Aegon three dragons if they were to make
a weapon that was powerful enough to
take down a dragon and specifically they
made long bows out of weirwood trees so
if that giant has a giant long boat made
out of weirwood trees that could be a
weapon that could take down Daenerys
dragon so moving on I like how when
branimir arrived at the north gate of
Castle black about brand is able to
prove his identity just by giving an
ominous warning and that's proof enough
for sounds like a Starks to me it's also
something you're asking how does brand
know that Edie was at the fish net
hardhome liked his brand of mind-readers
well he's not exactly a mine reader but
as the three-eyed Raven he does have a
near omniscient view of history that's
through all the faces of the weirwood
trees remember all those faces are kind
of recording history hasn't happened
throughout the ages of Westeros and bran
every a raven has access to all those
visions past and present and future
he's got the internet in his head now
moving on to one of these themes in the
Great Hall of Winterfell I feel like
we're gonna see a lot of things here
around this time if you want to talk
about what they have to do to get their
minds right and their people prepared to
take out the white Walker army and he's
very specifically a reference to
something that is unheard of the idea of
women and children not getting rescued
first but taking up arms and that is
something that is really fascinating
because even in our own history that has
happened from time to time now there are
definitely armies that have used women
for instance in the Israeli army the
reason why they've had to enlist women
and their force is because there's just
not enough people to give them a proper
defense without women or really the idea
that times are so dire that even
children must take up arms reminds me a
lot of the American Revolution where
really I mean if you were 13 you were
welled enough to go into battle and this
is even worse than that situation I just
really showed you how dire things have
gotten Walt but there's one slight
glimmer of
something positive out of that notice
that John snow has just started the end
of the aid of women being treated
differently for men Brian's been on this
path for a long time but someone like
the king of them all finally embracing
the idea that women can fight this as
well as men that at least for the future
of Westeros could be great yeah and if
you think about it it was really Ygritte
who instilled that idea of chivalry
having to come to an end in John so
really by making this argument he's
honoring her memory but one really cool
thing about this Phoenix if you look
closely the editing and the reaction
shock of all the characters are really
telling a secret conversation that's
going on during John speech yeah if you
were watching this and you were like I
feel like there's something going on
between all these people you're right
we're going to break that down page each
person here is actually thinking about
someone that they've lost right so we
start with sad ass little lady Lyanna
Mormont that was plenty sick and she's
staring at Brienne admiring this female
warrior and it's reminded her of her
mother mage Mormont who has that way she
was a great warrior as well but then
when John says not just the boys that
wasn't an impression at all I thought it
was God a whisper I thought especially
my magical Brienne looks over at John
and she's impressed that he would allow
women to serve boom she's being reminded
of Renly Baratheon he let her serve and
then Lyanna interrupts Lord lover by
saying I will miss while I let men serve
for me and Brienne nods approving and in
that moment Liana reminds her of herself
as a young girl picking fights with
these bigger men and then Davos smirks
the moment when Leanne interrupts lover
again and of course he's thinking about
Shireen Baratheon and those how a smile
stays a little bit because guys
remembering what happened to her each
one of them is reminiscing about someone
they've lost or version of themselves as
they block and it's all done through
editing that's awesome okay so right
here John starts dropping some important
references to places on a map and it
just hardhome each watched by to see car
hold the last part if you think about it
this is really the first time on the
show where they really started to define
where things are in relation to each
other on the map like in a pack has just
been kind of like they're in the north
right now or the south or they're very
far away mass of course have been shown
clean the opening credit sequence but
usually it's really zoomed in and we
don't really get a sense of where things
are but this episode changes all of that
and not just in the way where it's like
great we know geography better now it's
actually a thematic reason they're
introducing all of these maps and the
talk about where everyone is and
specifically how near they are so one of
the major themes of this episode is that
the world as we know it is shrinking
people and places are coming together
getting a little too close to each other
it's becoming almost a small town where
you can't even avoid bumping into each
other we're becoming four by three no no
no no and this whole idea of geography
and maps and where things are relation
to each other comes up throughout this
episode and will point it out as we go
next up notice that when Sansa openly
divides John Pinter costume now this is
totally new for the season costume
designer Michelle Clapton described this
as she wanted a real strength and she
wanted to answer to have embraced
everything that's happened to her and
wear it like armor much like how tyrion
told Jon Snow to do about the things
that have attacked him well running down
our style expert goes all right
designers I've got a heavy belt that
wraps around the neck it goes to the
waistline covering a double-breasted
dress basically the idea is you wanted
to tip in a monologue to be no one will
ever get coming again then check out
that circular necklace that evokes the
one back from Black Swan suspected to
term back in season four also we want to
work in some of the feathers from that
dress back in the area but then if you
look super closely look at the pattern
of the stitching the designer wanted
that to look like fishes swimming of
course to honor her mother tacklin who
was a Tully so sense is really taking
all of her influences and all of her
mentors and experiences good or bad and
combining them and putting them together
and saying like yeah I'm going to wear
that and the result of that is that it
said mal kind of has it seeming
combative relationships with John when
they disagree John says that famous line
from that starts at the man who passes
the sentence should swing the sword
now of course Rob start lived by that
advice as well which led him to execute
Rickard stark during the world of five
kings and that of course doomed him into
needing more troops having to try to
work with phrase and that was a very bad
idea and then that resulted in the car
starts turning against Robb Stark
abandoning him in the war and forcing
Robb Stark
to the red wedding and really that
insistence on justice the father's
justice is what doomed Robb Stark as
well just doomed Ned Stark and Sansa is
really mistakenly trying to advise Jon
on doing the same by pissing off all the
Karstarks in the name of justice instead
of taking her advice John actually
decides I'm not going to punish a man
for his father soon
now John isn't only thinking about this
one instance you got to remember that
John himself was punished for being a
bastard by Catelyn Stark she was so
incredibly mean to him because of
something that he didn't do but rather
his father's deeds
ironically this is the idea of John
showing the mothers mercy even though he
never saw that from his mother but also
something that sets up really nicely is
that John Pye not going to hold the
Targaryen deeds against Daenerys either
but moving on let's talk about the two
sweet kids who thankfully John's fair is
justice their neck amber and Alex
Karstark and that of course is probably
made after Ned Stark and that kills on a
sword might be familiar to you see those
two amber chain circle this is the same
store that small Jon number used and his
father Greatjon umber back in season one
there's a bit of another theme running
through this episode and we see the
beginning of it with this idea that
Ward's of yesterday don't matter anymore
now of course John is referring to the
war of the five kings and the divisions
there but in our real world that reminds
me a lot of what happened with us in
World War two the Allied powers being
composed of our former enemies France
and Britain were really old rivals and
so were the US and Britain actually in
bottle wars in the Bennigan's right and
then very famously the US and the USSR
hated each other and yet again this is
an instance where that doesn't matter
anymore there's a greater threat and
this lesson then come back a little bit
later but before we get to that equally
in-depth important concept let's explain
a poop joke no subs on quote a less
honorable line from his father
everything before the wood both this
whole [ __ ] and it's already explained
this joke but yeah I think about it
everything before a horse's bus is
literally you get the idea it wouldn't
be a scre but well it is a constipated
horse oh the constipated force anyway
after John and Sansa make up as brother
and sister or president comes in
whenever John receives
Circe's letter and we can see if you
look closely at what's written on the
piece of paper firstly calls John the
rebel and a bastard Jon Snow and then
when his ask them what it said Jon
repeats every part of his litter but he
conveniently leaves off that part and
it's probably because he's still afraid
of being undermined not only because
he's sensitive to the word bastard after
Ramsay's pink letter where he's had word
repeatedly but also saying the word
bastard in front of Sansa could remind
her that really his claim is not quite
as legitimate as hers and of course you
might remember cirsleep saying the
phrase bend the knee is the same empty
assurance which she gave me Ned Stark
back in season one eventually he did end
up bending to me and look how about for
now Fork and as we get into the debate
that Jon and fans are having they talk
about how there's one enemy that he's
been consumed with in the North Jamie's
forgot all about the one to the south
now that specific idea of potentially
fighting a war on two fronts has been
the decider in a lot of different wars
including one of the major reasons why
we won world war 2 also discussing how
many miles that are between them and
Cersei we're really diving into this map
and measurement of the geography and
again it's hitting home that not only is
Westeros shrinking but classes
specifically feels it's shrinking from
the south John feels it's shrinking from
the north I know
Sansa Jon actually kind of knows what
he's talking about attacking from the
south into the north is so incredibly
difficult it's rarely ever been done in
the history of Westeros and there's
monsters within 300 miles of it listen
to your big bro yeah and notice how John
accuses Sansa of admiring Cersei and she
doesn't deny it and funny coincidence
here notice how her hair is the same
style as Circe's in the past so once
again there's another example of some
past influencer working its way into
Tessa's wardrobe speaking of says back
to mine we gotta move on to King's
Landing and Westeros again hitting our
theme home is literally shrunken down
underneath the foot of a giant Cersei
stepping on the map yeah and as we see
this clear bird's-eye view of Westeros
Jamie says this episode's title Kraken
style it's interesting how the location
of Dragonstone is kind of become a
symbol for this whole idea it used to be
this far away isolated place for a
Spanish asset and simmered for several
seasons and then we see it on the map
specifically how close it is to King's
Landing that is so crazy like if you
want to really understand how close that
is go watch Westeros Weekly we've got an
awesome map thing that I built in the
middle of the night and I stayed up all
night to in it but where we can actually
see how close everyone
I'm saying they can like see each other
I'm going to reach out and slap each
other in the face took it not success
but really the point here if you look at
the map and you see these pieces is all
reminiscent also of a game board like
you're playing Settlers of Catan or
something and really that's another
theme in this episode everyone pausing
and taking a moment to figure out their
strategy of what is going to be their
next move in the game as Gandalf would
say it's the board is set and the pieces
are moving right are you going to put
that town on a brick in or and no no
settlers are some of the fan reference I
don't want it let's go move on
notice how Webster's we list all these
different female enemies of her usually
different offensive female slur for each
of them which we can't really say but I
can say any of them which is clear that
Circe is not really a woman other women
would look up to because she hates every
woman who was in her oh also I just
gotta say I think we all loved it Jamie
when he calls out by the way queen of
Seven Kingdoms tries three kingdoms at
that what's amazing is that he's not
wrong about any of the monarchs that
have rolled here even a Don the
Conqueror wasn't able to roll over Dorne
so really ruling the Seven Kingdoms is
something that people just kind of say
now a lot of you are wondering which
Kingdom they kind of have under them
still our best guess is that he's
referring to the Western land where
Casterly Rock is located of course and
then the storm lands where Baratheon
territory storms end is it doesn't seem
like they're up and we're going to get
some rest and then it seems like the
Riverlands are still under the control
even though Arya has wiped out the
phrase which is like kind of like adds
that yeah meanwhile the north to reach
the Vale and Dorne are all in open
rebellion against the crown
so Jeremy Podesta the director of this
episode he loves to play with size and
perspective one thing he does a lot is
show these huge wide shots but also
something he does is play with angles to
make false size implications throughout
a scene and it happens here between
Cersei and Jaime know specifically at
the beginning of the scene Cersei
appears like a giant crushing Westeros
right at the next she looks like she's
towering over Jaime especially she's
reminding him that he's the one that let
Tyrion get away then Jaime joins Cersei
on the map and he kind of offers his
wisdom and now they look about equal
size but then there's a really dramatic
shift when Tommen gets brought up right
notice how Sir she literally retreats
from this conversation
and now Jamie looks noticeably larger
Percy's eyeline has changed you have to
look up at him because he had the moral
high ground now and then finally when
Cersei reveals that she won't war in
common and she has no heart left Jamie
goes back and stands on a map alone
exactly where Cersei began the scene on
the plains
he is a giant now and she looks small
now moving on to your on Greyjoy fleet
personally I got a call-out that badass
ship the thing looks like it's straight
out of a Jules Verne novel it matches
the description of the books by the way
with the multiple side sails are the
Greyjoy cracking on the bow two
battering ram extensions one on the
bottom which sounds like almost like a
snowplow or somebody just push other
small boats out of the way or something
and then there's the one more jagged one
designed to actually puncture freakin
hulls that ship is real good at stabbing
other ships also note that it's very
ready for battle the shield's lined up
on the side of the deck which helps
block against projectiles and arrows now
in a cenote so everyone has changed
armor Jamie included but I got some
mountains new armor this black Darth
Vader II whipping armor is now the
standard rubber of all the Kingsguard
and I think Darth Vader really was a
model for creating this kind of armor in
fact in Star Wars all the Empire's armor
and uniforms that were bottled off of
the Germans in World War 2 the servant
servers actually got that name from the
not confirmed troopers these new
Kingsguard helmets like the term server
helmet cover their faces make them look
more conformance inhuman robotically
machines all like the mountain I think
Cersei may be just being so sweet and
her now boy of hers that is kind of the
close link she has decide is the
mountain and she feels bad that he has
to cover his ugly face he's like well
everyone else will cover their face and
no one will laugh at you mountain she's
just arranging playdates with all the
king's daughter they all have to be
there yeah and yes you're looking at the
background here you probably noticed
that there now these red Lannister
banners hanging from the wall which
means that Cersei replaced all the
Baratheon stags with Lannister lions as
well as the seven-pointed star stained
glass window in the throne room which
you replaced with a lancer lion but
that's not all that changed look at this
guy's
Hey okay we got to talk about your on
costume and his delivery a lot of people
feel like it may be changed abruptly I
actually think this is just the way he
is he's manipulative he's different
around a woman that he's trying to
seduce in the men that he was trying to
aspire earlier but mostly Xena notices
the guy looks like a freaking rock star
a lot of people might compare him to
Jack Sparrow but you gotta remember Jack
Sparrow was based on a rock star Keith
Richards from The Rolling Stone
it's also worth pointing out it's not
the craziest transformation this is a
lot more what he was like in the book he
was flamboyant he was kind of addicted
to the equivalent of heroin in the books
as well so he's basically your classic
rock star has just been waiting for a
lady to perform in front of ya and that
seduction remember was actually intended
for another Queen Daenerys that's what
you're talking about when he won big
give her this big you know but really
now that Theon and Yara beat him to the
punch
he has swapped out one Queen for another
and didn't change his tactic at all I'm
sure Cersei would not like knowing this
side by the way but something else that
he uses to try to get to her is the fact
that she has a traitorous family member
he has a traitor's family member I
really like though Jamie reminding both
of them that he actually was the first
trader of sibling
when he murdered his brother and he's
also encouraging Cersei to become a
traders family member so you can get
away sir she's like yeah I can't trust
this kind of crazy but I think she will
eventually actually and of course if you
were paying attention drawn suddenly
reminds us of the theme of this episode
he said that he actually was cool with
Jaime killing all of his hand on the
iron islands because it was getting too
crowded the world as he knew it was
shrinking
he also touches on geography with
offering to kill the invaders beast and
pretenders to the north and south by the
way there's a lot of debate about what
your own gift is going to be we've had
some ideas in westeros Weekly but since
if you want to know what you guys think
as gift is going to be so let us know in
the comments what it could be I have a
theory about a certain implants have a
different one okay moving on to Oldtown
and guys we got to talk about this
disgusting montage but just like in
Winterfell earlier the editing is really
effective at telling us stories without
using any dialogue notice how all the
sound cues sync up with the sound of the
pouring soup smacking the sound of the
pouring shakes
notice the specific choice to cut from a
bowl those whose got poop in it to a
bowl of a sip that they eat and yeah
telling this non-verbally makes it way
more interesting like imagine we could
have had a boring scene with him
complaining about his job the Gili as he
comes home covered in the majors crash
but instead using this repetition in
shock imagery makes us feel exactly what
Sam is feeling in this moment boredom
and disgust what they're doing basically
is what Edgar Wright does he can tell a
whole story and a lot of character back
to him what's been going on in this
guy's life by using these tight
close-ups these staccato cuts you've
seen in Shaun of the Dead you saw it in
Hot Fuzz the world and he actually just
saw and baby drivers go check out our
baby driver video but really it's just a
really fun way to show the passage of
time that is packed with information
yeah and really the only break that Sam
gets in this routine is this rare
glimpse of an open textbook inside this
forbidden section if you look closely
the only some Meister is trying to
explain how this planet orbits around
the Sun in its solar system now this
isn't just some nerdy Mason's obsessed
with astronomy which is actually pretty
cool so I don't know I thought nerdy
seasons are impacted by where the planet
is located in its orbit around the Sun
and seasons are the entirety of the
generation of the drama that causes this
game of Thrones with the North having
its forever winter and the south beam
and summer for years and years and years
so there's actually two really
fascinating theories as to what is up
with this planet why they could have
winter for so long and then summer for
so long and one of them is tied to the
magic of the White Walkers themselves
yeah let's look back at that opening
image remember the wind was blowing one
way away from camera whereas the white
Walker cloud is bringing winter toward
us so my thought is is that maybe the
winds of winter aren't something natural
it's something that the White Walkers
control themselves
remember back in last season we saw when
the White Walkers are created that whole
tree area went from a summery look to a
wintry look it's as if the season of
winter didn't exist until the White
Walkers were created in fact if you
remember when we saw the White Walkers
first get created that whole region
wherever it was went from nice warm
summer to later when we saw the same
location to cold dead winter the
implication being that maybe the whole
season of winter didn't exist
this world until the magic that created
the White Walkers created that season as
well so that's the magic theory but the
second theory I think is super
interesting because there's actually a
scientific reason why this all might be
happening but first
shocker we have to pay to make these
videos and our sponsor and helping us
out and paying for this video it squid
thank you so much to them again they pay
for these exact videos and luckily it's
actually a pretty cool sponsor quit is
this awesome new app where you can
collect these stickers and cards and 3d
figures for free all on your phone
instead of using like emojis you can
actually make jokes with your friends in
the conversation with their stickers
from your favorite property and what's
special about squid is that they have
thousands of free stickers that you
can't find anywhere else specifically
from these shows that we love like booms
they just finally got Game of Thrones
I've been using Rick and Morty stickers
all week but now I'm gonna switch over
to Game of Thrones stickers so I can
drop you know nothing Jon Snow some Jeff
Harris heat fire and just like saucy
little character cut out and literally
you just like drag and drop it onto your
iMessage they also do these cool 3d
recreations of those Funko pop figures
and we're going to do a giveaway for all
you guys where if you follow new rock
stars on Twitter and share this video
with the hashtag house new rock stars
will pick some of you randomly and send
you a Funko pop final Game of Thrones
figures boom / freeze just for sharing
the video oh and buy to buy it we came
up with our own stickers around there
that I think are hilarious to point out
the quick state of your own text
messages and then also you can just make
your own stickers from your own pictures
that's a new feature they just released
but they also come out with a bunch more
every single day anyway just click on
the link below in the description and
hit us up on Twitter username is new
Rockstar has been sharing some stickers
with us you can trade and we got a real
good collection but back to that second
theory about the weird seasons of
Westeros we've got some magic region but
I love the science reason there were
grad students at John Hopkins who wrote
entire entire freakin thesis arguing
that Game of Thrones a regular season
could be the result of a binary stars to
some like two suns like freakin Tatooine
style and the planet is actually
orbiting the Suns almost in like a
figure eight pattern which would make
the seasons extremely irregular and
unpredictable except for people that
lived thousands of years maybe would
eventually find a pattern that's maybe
lady Melisandre figured it out now our
meister ebro's that's played by Jim
Broadbent and you may recognize that he
played Professor Slughorn in the Harry
Potter movies and this is interesting
because this is the same kind of
scenario right there's a student
approaching a professor about accessing
these books in a restricted section and
learning about this old magic a
restriction section is a common thing in
libraries I want to know what's behind
mine I'll be grown-up stuff yeah and
notice what ebro's says here the
simplest explanation for your grating
obsession with the White Walkers is that
you're telling the truth Burroughs is
applying the concept of Occam's razor
you know where you remove all the
unnecessary explanations as if you're
doing it with a razor before arriving at
the simplest answer and what's great
about this is actually using this
concept as he's literally doing that
with the scientific method through his
autopsy he's cutting away all the organs
that are not the explanation that leads
to this man's death and finally arises
the most obvious answer
he's got liver disease from alcoholism
that thing's huge I thought it was a
baby
also of course libros brings us back to
that idea of math and geography not like
the people cells as a twins we don't
like to be the loss of the twins what
this lecture ebuddy gives Sam about the
world never truly ending an interesting
rule stood through it all
honestly this guy kind of sounds like
those experts who said that the Titanic
was unsinkable or the Hindenburg was
unexploded unpoppable
the wall will never go down but anyway
let's actually fast-forward past forming
a brain doing the IO fencing and Sanford
coldly shutting down little fingers and
we're gonna go to boom the thing that
everybody on the internet is talking
about Ed's freaking sure and it feels
almost like a different show and it's on
screen how far do we fast-forward also
keep in mind Game of Thrones has
featured a lot of cameos by real-life
musicians like the turban from Coldplay
sugar rose of Monsters and Men and the
main soldier in this scene is the son of
late character actor piece possibly
that's kind of a distracting cameo to
write now no one caught that at all yeah
there actually is a cool backstory to
the lyrics of the song he's singing oh
and the book that same song is sung by
Simon silver tongue and he's a fat belly
singer in King's Landing who finds out
about Tyrians relationship with shea and
he tries to blackmail him through the
song it's about a guy who came down from
his Hill through the streets of the city
to see his hidden
a chain and a keep are nothing a
referring to Tyrians red Keith and the
team used to sync Stannis's fleet in the
Battle of Blackwater but then Tyrion
orders Bronn to make this singer
disappear so they can't blackmail and
it's implied that bran dumps the
singer's body into this well known stood
that Cerf complete bottom has filled
with a bunch of weird meat that came
from weird places so if you aren't the
biggest fan of Ed Sheeran bean and Game
of Thrones maybe the show will use this
story in a very fun way with this
Lannister singer finding out about are a
secret and then trying to blackmail her
and then orchid turning him into a
delicious ginger flavor - well I find
fascinating about that is that she's
really at a crossroads she could be
reminded of the love of her family and
the good in people
or she can go down a real dark path and
cooked up Sheeran boy and let's take a
look at those two different branches
they give you two different ways of
looking at the scene like when it's in a
more positive light Arya is hitting it
off with Lannister soldiers but what if
Lannister bannermen on the road ever
been nice in the show she's finding
their common humanity and this almost
feels like another world war 2 reference
because doesn't feel like this scene
could be right out of Saving Private
Ryan like all these soldiers away from
home sharing their memories of to their
family members but there's a much darker
way of looking at it so notice how the
soldiers mentioned how they used to want
to get away now they just want to go
home once Goss is the idea of fighting
in another man's war Arya if she's dark
minded she's thinking hey these
Lannisters have lost their will to fight
she even test the resolved by
straight-up admitting that she's going
to fascinate their queen so in that
version Arya could be taking up the role
of Lady Stoneheart from the book she's
the murders threat in the Riverlands
she's just taking out any men from the
families that wronged her family and
Beyond Lady Stoneheart Arya might be
representing an even bigger figure this
line from the Lannister soldiers well
mother always told me to be conscious
find us strangers become to you so I
think there's some symbolism here this
stranger is one of these seven new gods
and unlike those other guys people
rarely ever pray to the stranger they
fear that figure because he or she no
one really knows what the figure looks
like represents death and traits of the
other seven appear and a lot of
characters on the show but Arya is
clearly the stranger now
for time and exile and time with the
faceless men has made her into this
anonymous deadly figure no one knows her
true appearance and because we just saw
her wipe out an entire house and these
Lannister men don't realize it but
they're having dinner with death right
now
the person who caused the Riverland
chaos as they're supposed to contain is
this person and this soldier has no idea
how wise he is by being kind to the
stranger but she might cook them in
those two anyway and if it is that
darker version of arias journey it's
interesting that we're now immediately
moving on to the opposite version of
that journey with the other part of her
famous duo Sandra Clegane the Hound who
appears to be coming into the light and
we know that because this farmhouse is
the same location that they stayed at in
season 4 remember he stole his farmer
silver and he left him injured and he is
feeling this guilt in this moment that's
why I didn't want to stay there he's
probably the reason why this guy said so
that feeling sets up that when they're
inside of the house how does questioning
barrack about why the Lord of Light
would bring back a man like him who's
not special he's actually talking about
himself he feels guilty that he gets to
stay alive and in a way keeps coming
back to and I love this line from The
Hound as my talking law kinda was a band
of fire worshippers this is a huge
moment for him the contrition he feels
for causing these innocents to die leads
him to facing his longtime fear of fire
his greatest vulnerability is now
becoming a source of strength
it's actually really comments story
telling that the hero be tested with his
most elemental fear specifically one
that's often a little associated with
maybe the fear of a child and that
always ends up being a huge part of
their growth yeah so for example there
was Indiana Jones who famously hate
snakes so it happened to him in that
movie yeah he gets thrown in a snake pit
and in the more thematic example there
was Chris Nolan's Batman movies Bruce
Wayne learns to embrace the bat which is
something experiment as a kid later he
has a symbol that he can use against his
enemy so now Clegane is having to
embrace the fire as the new thing he's
going to worship and when the hound
looks into the flames
he sees the wall and a castle by the sea
now this probably referencing
eastwatch-by-the-sea
which is the same castle that tormund is
going to and then yeah look what
happened buddy brings it up fire log
snaps obviously we aren't meant to
expect this castle to roll
for much longer will torment survive
[Music]
that's actually my real question and
yeah I'm betting that the Brotherhood is
now headed to the same location also a
quick reminder about where we've left
head the Hound in the book we still
don't know where he is but there's a
theory that he might be this gravedigger
that we see in a feast for crows now
that's been a huge fan theory for a long
time so it feels like this moment is
actually acknowledgment that yeah that
probably is him in the books too and
before we move on from this notice the
prayers of the houses after he buries
the father and daughter the Hound is
starting to remember the prayer that the
father said to bless a meal but the
Hound doesn't remember how it goes
because he cut him up we asked the
father to judge us with mercy
you know it's the mother I don't
remember the rest back to Old Town the
most exciting place in Westeros and now
has a book about dragonglass which Jon
specifically has just talked about all
the maesters looking for information
about dragonglass well here it is
but specifics want to point out this
drawing of this dagger that looks
exactly like the same dagger that
Littlefinger gave to the assassin to
kill branch way back in season one yeah
exactly was a photo shoot of everyone in
costume and the cover of Entertainment
Weekly showed Arya carrying that same
dagger at her hip so Arya could get this
dagger before this season's over
in a way clearly the show intent for
this dagger to come back in some way the
question is how will Arya get it and if
it ends up being kind of a smoking gun
for Littlefinger's actual involvement in
branch assassination attempt this dagger
could break down the whole house of
Baelish which is like one person good
but also as Sam does mention that
Stannis had previously brought up the
dragon glass existed on Dragonstone so
that conversation not a striking class a
mountain events town is totally but I
didn't
she's important but also notice that he
specifically says a mountain of
dragonglass
that is a callback to the end of that
same season where John snows
specifically tells Sam we're going to
need a mountain of it if we want to beat
the White Walkers things are looking
pretty good for everyone except Jorah
Mormont
yes that is his hand that lunges out at
Sam at Old Town and notice how severe
the greyscale has gotten it's
practically falling apart now but I
think the reason we're seeing joy here
is that Sam could use the dragon glass
securin what yeah if you look at the
previous scene another inscription that
is barely visible in frame seems to
describe something about how dragon
glass can be used as a medicine to treat
illnesses okay
and then if we think about the only
person that we've seen on this show to
be kind of cured from greyscale was
Shireen named after head Shireen and
it's possible that the remedy that the
maesters used on her would be from her
home of Dragonstone the natural dragon
glass that was all around the castle
yeah and let's not stop there the person
who talked to Shireen about that
experience the person who might be able
to bring this solution to the forefront
the possible hero of all of Westeros is
right in this room you know not Sam
Gilly Gilly and Shireen bonded at the
wall in season five when Shireen
tusculum how to read all and maybe Gilly
would have some insight though on how
dragonglass plays into carrying
greyscale all those maesters are going
to get schooled by Gilly okay let's move
on to this final sequence at Dragonstone
now notice this is five and a half
minutes of no dialogue so just like Sam
poop and flute montage and that opening
two-minute shot it's so interesting how
they're using editing to tell this story
without using any words that all the
visuals are powerful enough we're
actually going to do an in-depth
breakdown here everything that's going
on to tell the story of how Danny is
finally back at her rightful familial
home Dragonstone was the home of
Targaryen ever since Aegon the Conqueror
ik landed there many millennia ago it
happens to have changed hands a couple
of times since then but this is her
finally reconnecting with her actual
birthplace and the birthplace of her
family in Westeros but again talking
about how the visuals are helping tell
the story and let's start with the
costumes what everyone's wearing okay so
yes Daenerys and clothes have changed
from when she was queen of marine and
SOS pasties and she wore
whites and tan the colors of that
continent but returning the West Rose
now she wouldn't really be dressed to
the part of she was wearing that so now
she wears all blacks in fact everyone in
her Posse is wearing black these colors
probably advised her by Tyrion or with a
look of a true ruler in Westeros other
things helping her look apart to notice
the stiff shoulders that match the
unsullied army she commands the crimson
kate that reflected esterases lust of
black in the red it's all like what
dance is doing Danny is embracing her
past tormentors wearing them like armor
and replacing Viserys as the same
Targaryen orphan that would return to
Westeros with an army and capes are
really in right now by the by in the
chain which the designer calls a chain
of command goes down into this subtle
dragon head headpiece which isn't a full
crown and that's intentional because
Daenerys hasn't conquered yet but also
it's not just about the visuals that are
happening here the music is also playing
a huge part Ramin Djawadi is House
Targaryen theme is plated but he mixes
in the main game of throne cream when
she reaches the gate to signal that
Danny is in Westeros now she's joining
the other power players in a major
Westeros new seat of power and she's
officially entered the game and then
inside we get more visual storytelling
with the whole set design of Dragonstone
it's interesting to see why this place
is so hard to siege after the gates you
have to cross this long narrow pathway
that soldiers have pretty much have to
climb in single file while everyone in
the castle will just rain down hell and
arrows and rocks on them in fact I think
this could be inspired by the hell deep
design in Lord of the Rings of two
towers and then carrying over the
visuals from outside inside the dragon
stones throne room designers perfectly
made the throne look like the natural
rock formations from outside freaking
crashed into the room and they just
decided to turn that into the throne and
while it's way less ornate in the famous
throne room in Westeros and Kings
landings they do have to be in common
potentially if this is dragon glass and
those are both Thrones that are made a
very important weapon and another thing
in common with the King's Landing Castle
just like Cersei did there Daenerys is
replacing the oldest Signia with the new
she tears down Stannis's banner and
notice how now the camera lingers on all
this dragon imagery everywhere we have
the two big dragon heads outside the
dragon itched into the floor and then
the awesome dragon carving on the wall
in the map room
I still hope she's going to bring like
the property brothers in there to like
do it right but specifically they don't
need to touch the map room
this is Aegon Targaryen the map
he built this table Danny's gran gran
gran times a lot grandfather was here
and plotted his strategy for the
entirety of his invasion of Westeros
from this same room it's like breaking
george w bush planning another iraq war
from the same Situation Room that George
Herbert Walker busted I bet that was
intentional it's kidding it wasn't but
let's actually look closely at this shot
notice how it's symmetrical again that's
the director trademark and the reason he
does that here is because it connects it
back to that opening image from branch
point to be remembered that was also
symmetrical and both of these shots show
the biggest threats that West versus
faced in a long time both coming from
different directions and focusing
specifically on this closing shot so
notice three open windows we noticed
this somebody tweeted at us - you guys
are amazing by the way I always do that
we love it there are three spots open in
the window two of them are filled
Daenerys Tyrion and who's going to be
the third one well we refer to as a
third head of the Dragon John but of
course this map is meant to parallel
sources giant map effect Daenerys also
looked like a giant as she's running her
fingers along it meanwhile Tyrion just
like Jamie in that previous scene notes
to stay away letting the Queen play
Godzilla in the front we're telling you
right Matt's was is recurring motif all
throughout the episodes it was totally
on purpose but now we understand that
their maps in the way that a game is
played these people have set their
tables with their game board map and now
Danny's line shall we begin
it sounds like she's about to make the
first move in a game of chess or rolling
to see who gets to place that town on
that precious wheat or snow Settlers of
Catan I'm really for all of these
characters the world as they know it is
shrinking they're all within striking
distance of each other and they're
acutely aware of which direction their
enemies are coming from John Sansa
Cersei Jaime you're on Sam they're all
feeling the impact of a Westeros with
the walls closing in on that Cabral
you're onwards it's about to get really
crowded in here and I think we're going
to see some legit battles all season
long but strategically like you do in a
game it's all going to start at crack
the stone and we're not done yet we got
some big predictions where we think
that's going to go over the course of
this season first off I think we're
gonna get some big ring mints with aria
in fact if you're watching closely
during the opening credits they added a
new location that we quickly flew by The
Inn at the crossroads now this is the
last-known location of a couple
fascinating characters first Nymeria her
dire
who ran away and the woods around here
and then the big character everyone's
been asking about Popeye
oh yeah there's also another character I
think it's familiar with that place
who's been on a boat for a long time
could he have gone back there but also
another prediction Littlefinger's past
Medellin I think it's going to catch up
to him this season I think there's a
reason that we keep seeing this dagger
show up him and bran are going to be a
Winterfell at the same time
could he expose them it's Littlefinger's
pioneer enn will he survive why don't
you go in that voice all these questions
need answers and final prediction I
think team Daenerys is going to suffer
more than team Cersei over the season
like I know things seem down for Cersei
right now but I think that's intentional
fortunes always flip on the show and I
really think most of America's alliance
will either die or face some kind of
crippling defeat or if she wins she'll
just squeak by like I don't think Cersei
will let her reap the rewards of King's
Landing but again do not think sir she's
gonna come off safe I actually forgot to
point this out earlier when Cersei is a
class I'm the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms well you know what her dad
Tywin would have said that we do because
he said it before any man who must say I
am the king is no true king so she's not
gonna do great either but let us know
what you think in the comments you can
hit us up directly also on Twitter a TA
bus demo and you can follow new rock
stars on twitter at new rock stars also
watch left so strictly it's really great
with mana gear we made a lot of
predictions also specifically for just
next week's episode just called
Stormborn hmm was that a reference ooh I
saw a lot of people both playing and
yeah remember to share this video on
Twitter and if you follow us and go
through those steps remember you'll be
eligible for this awesome photo pop
giveaway also huge thanks to our girl
our patreon supporter Kelly hopper a lot
of you our patreon supporters and we're
gonna have some announcements at our
patreon real soon
I think are so exciting will of course
be back next week thank you for watching
if you'd like to see us play Settlers of
Catan on this channel
tweet at me nope just me now mom's
getting hot
definitely got a cut we got a cut